what's up guys Lord Sovereign here back
again for the iron Lords podcast and
lordsofgaming.net here at paxies 2023
we're here at the uh we're here with
Celia Schilling the marketing director
for Yacht Club games and we're going to
take a look at everything that Yacht
Club has to offer this year at PAX East
2023 so Celia thank you for joining us
oh thank you for stopping by it's
awesome so tell us uh what is the first
game you're gonna be looking at so we're
first going to be playing Shovel Knight
pocket dungeon
um it is a very Canon uh stuff adventure
for the Shovel Knight series uh we
developed it alongside Vine and it is a
roguelike adventure mixed with some
puzzle action it's it's really fun we
actually just announced um recently this
year uh some DLC for the game
um right now it's available on early
preview on Steam so if you own the base
game you can jump right into the action
okay fantastic so a little bit about
like what difference what makes it
different from the base itself on that
game what's different so today's Shovel
Knight uh to the DLC or uh or pop
dungeon the game yeah the DLC the DLC in
the in the game proper oh course so it
expands upon that it adds new um
playable characters it adds new relics
uh there's like Legacy Adventure where
we're naming the names right now it's
like the legendary path uh there's the
Quan G challenges you can explore a
quandary Castle there's so much more to
this game it is fantastic
um I know like of course I'm the
marketing director I'm gonna love our
games but I am addicted to pocket
dungeon so to have more content like
that is really exciting okay fantastic
let's see it yeah of course okay
so I usually play on keyboard so we'll
see how I feel so how pocket dungeon
works is that it does like kind of like
a match three so you see how these
enemies right here are the same they're
Cheetos yeah so you want to hit them the
thing is though every time you pick them
you trade damage do you want to make
sure to pick a potion these guys do two
damage you want to be aware of your
health teams before you go on to the
next interview and then you can do a lot
of Combos and like once you get really
good at the game it's all Focus you're
taking like a shovel my God
so right there what I did is
you could be aware of uh different
environmental challenges
prices
okay so as you play through the game
he's not viewable in the demo but he's
he's pretty cool too
[Music]
so essentially what you're trying to do
is
match as things are falling
so he matches your following and then
eventually you'll get in the level
usually I cleared a board but let me
just show you the keep on going
um so yeah then you get through an exit
and you completely
um speedrunners get crazy times my world
record is 26 seconds but damn the BP
beat me it's fine I understand
um and then so as you progress through
the levels you go to familiar places
like over in the planes and now we're at
Pride more
um and then after you go like a certain
amount of time
so after I beat this level
um we will encounter Specter Knight and
uh he does a familiar foe his last
friend in one of the other uh Chevrolet
Series game Specter of torment and
shovel of hope so if you're gonna return
to Fun Fair like fan favorite characters
you get to play and explore in new ways
oh that's great I love Treasure Trove
and you know and every aspect of the
original is amazing to me so to see you
guys take that and expand in all
different directions several night is
like a kind of a thing unto himself now
and it's amazing this was a kickstarted
game kickstarted sort of franchise and
see what it's become it's not it's
bonkers the city thank you I appreciate
it all right so this is a Shovel Knight
pocket dungeon the DLC will be out when
uh we haven't announced release date as
of yet but we're here
to our social media pages
[Music]
and uh yeah we'll make a lot of noise
when it's ready absolutely thank you so
much appreciate it